as the war in ukraine evolves so do
disinformation tactics we saw propaganda
from both sides aiming to manipulate
public opinion and the information
provided inside of russia tells a much
different story than the information the
rest of the world has access to
here's an example where russian tv show
claims that ukrainian soldiers use
children as human shields that no proof
provided for these statements there have
also been claims that the ukrainian army
has nearly run out of weapons and
ammunition in reality the resistance of
ukraine's army is still significant and
strong
another false claim says only the united
states is involved in fighting against
russia and ukraine from the ukrainian
side there have also been deep fake
videos that have emerged from social
media
well for more on the information war
let's cross over to joshua weber he's
head of dw's fact-checking team in bonn
yoshi what does the propaganda regarding
the war in ukraine look like
well it has many different faces if we
look to russia reports by the state
control television channels like we've
seen before have a big influence on the
public opinion after a month of war in
ukraine it's obvious that russian
propaganda has now shifted gears russia
is blocking social networks launching
its own new networks like rosgram a
russian version of instagram and they
target the public opinion in western
societies by yeah something like this uh
tweets by embassies here we see some
tweets of
the german embassy claiming that there
is no free speech yeah there were
pro-russian demonstrations going on so
this claim is baseless or this other
claim from the russian from the russian
embassy in the uk
where we see some claims on uh that the
maripo hospital attack was staged that
is not true fact checkers around the
globe collected a lot of evidence like
videos satellite pictures and so on
eyewitness accounts to prove that these
claims are baseless and the embassy
tweet has been deleted now so we've seen
a use of fake videos being created using
artificial intelligence so-called deep
fakes how exactly is this being done
yes we're talking about these deep fakes
they are the highest art of deception we
can say gerhard videos and images are
manipulated by using powerful techniques
from machine learning and ai in the
following video russian president
vladimir putin allegedly announces peace
with the ukraine but putin didn't say
that exactly the images from this speech
before the start of the war but the
audio track has been changed you can
find the original video by doing a
reverse image search if you then compare
both videos you can see a lot of
similarities
and you can see that at one particular
point at this video there was uh the
same hand movement so
this is something yeah we can we can
find out by using tools of digital
research and fact checking
and uh actually the same thing like
putin happened to vladimir silensky from
ukraine uh we have another video
prepared for you um and it announces the
surrender of ukraine
said by
silenski wrong again
and you have to look at the details
zelensky's head and lip movements look
odd the body proportions themselves
aren't right either his shoulders do not
move at all so the background um and his
face were taken from photos from a press
conference and then got remixed in this
deep face
so this is you explained how your team
is debunking uh those videos
um but if how can average people decide
what's true and whatnot if both sides of
a conflict use this information how can
we really know what happens
yeah actually um there are several ways
to do that but it's always a good advice
yeah to
check and not to interact all of sudden
we even saw some fake fact checks in
russian media claiming to do debunking
but actually lying about facts so be
skeptical think before you share and do
it like we do ask questions can it be
real can i trace the origin of the
picture and how trustworthy is the
source of the information a lot of fakes
try to trigger us by using emotional or
controversial topics so if you come
across something like this yeah take a
deep breath double check before you
interact
always a good idea josh weber head of
our fact-checking department thank you
very much joshua